bonjour christian lequesne qu'est ce qui
se joue aujourd'hui pour l'ukraine et en
quoi est-ce centrale pour kfc
centrale parce que ça mais kiev si vous
voulez dans un processus qui va mener au
rapprochement institutionnel avec
l'union européenne comme vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure personne ne sait combien
de temps ça va durer mais ce qui est
important c'est que le processus
s'engage et bien entendu compte tenu des
velléités russe d'un excellent ukraine
cela renforce le choix de l'ukraine d'
aller plutôt vers les valeurs le système
politique de l'europe que celui que
celui de la russie donc c'est un c'est
un point extrêmement extrêmement
important pour pour les ukrainiens même
si pour l'instant la paix n'est pas
encore gagné et si les ukrainiens ça
parfaitement que ce processus
d'élargissement prendra des années oui
c'est ça c'est un statut de candidat qui
ne gâte rentiers rien finalement sur
l'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'union
européenne on n'en est pas là
absolument accepter le statut de
candidat ne veut pas dire accepter
l'état
il ya des procédures très longues il
faut ensuite on vote à l'unanimité
l'ouverture de procédures de négociation
il faut ensuite négocier les chapitres
si vous voulez politique par politique
la question du marché la question de
l'énergie etc etc il faut modifier sa
législation nationale
et puis ensuite il ya un vote à la fin
pour pour accepter
d'abord la conclusion des négociations
et après après il n'a encore une
ratification
de la part de chacun des états membres
de l'union européenne et de l'état
candidat dont vous voyez tout ça est un
est un long processus allant processus
qui devrait qui pourrait durer combien
de temps des années des décennies
c'est très difficile à dire mais nous
avons des expériences passées si vous
prenez les pays d'europe centrale et
orientale la pologne la république
tchèque qui sont entrés en 2004 le dépôt
de leur candidature c'est 1994 grosso
modo il a fallu il a fallu dix ans si
vous prenez l'espagne le dépôt de
candidature c'est
1977 pour une entrée en 1986 qu'il a
fallu neuf ans quand vous voyez cessé de
l'ordre souvent d'au moins 10 ans voilà
mais après tout dépend de de l'état de
la législation tout dépend de l'état du
pays en quelque sorte ce qui est certain
c'est que on ne peut pas envisager
d'ouverture de négociations tant que la
peine ne sera pas drôle
justement qu'est-ce que l'ukraine doit
améliorer ou changer pour avoir une
chance un jour de rejoindre les 27 elle
doit travailler sur tous les éléments de
l'état de droit c'est à dire la question
d'abord de l'indépendance sa justice et
un point absolument
fondamental il ya une corruption chez
les juges là je parle de la situation
d'avant la guerre qui il croit même très
forte et puis il faut améliorer de
manière générale tous les points de
fonctionnement de la démocratie la
démocratie c'est pas seulement des
élections libres la démocratie c'est
aussi un certain nombre de mécanismes
ensuite qui permettent à l'état de droit
de fonctionner donc qu'il ya du boulot
si je puis dire mais les teams chrétien
le le savent et je pense que l'invasion
russe a été aussi une sorte de sursaut
pour dire vraiment les valeurs
auxquelles nous croyons ce sont les
valeurs de l'europe et donc nous devons
nous rapprocher les standards de
l'europe reste avec snow christian
lequesne j'aimerais qu'on aborde dans un
instant l'idée de communauté politique
qui a été avancé par emmanuel macron
c'est un peu une entre eux deux avant
cela caroline de camaret je crois que la
connexion a été rétablie notre envoyé
spécial à bruxelles on est dithyrambique
1 depuis ce matin caroline de camaret au
sein du conseil européen on présente
cette journée comme historique
oui tout à fait parce que c'est vrai que
on n'aurait pas pu penser il y a
quelques mois que cette candidature
express de l'ukraine était possible et
qu'elles fassent surtout l'unanimité des
27 il ya quand même on l'a dit un
quelques réticences du côté des pays bas
des pays nordiques qui sont très
rigoriste 1 par rapport à l'état de
droit est effectivement un état de
corruption endémique en ukraine qui les
inquiète mais en vérité est bien la
commission européenne l'a proposé et les
vingt-sept voir le fer vont le faire
parce que tout simplement ils
considèrent que c'est un geste politique
fort c'est une véritable victoire
d'ailleurs pour le président et
l'inscrit en tant que tels que cette
candidature qui abîment beaucoup moins
de temps que sané
coutumier alors derrière il ya quand
même aussi la moldavie la moldavie c'est
cet autre petit état qui a notamment à
une partie séparatistes tous contre
l'ukraine qui jouxte d'ailleurs
l'ukraine avec la possibilité peut-être
que que les russes puisque c'est une
partie séparatiste pro-russe essaye de
faire la jonction et donc on lui donne
aussi ce statut de candidat parce que il
a profité de l'effet ukraine est par
contre il y à la géorgie qui a deux
régions séparatistes pro russes mais
elles ne se voient pas accorder ce
statut parce que eh bien la géorgie est
beaucoup trop loin dans la voie des
réformes et en particulier elle a deux
grands partis qu'ils sont en crise
politique permanente et ardu et donc
elle n'obtient pas ce statut et ce
statut en tout cas qui sera
crédité à l'ukraine fait grincer des
dents vous parlez de la la géorgie
caroline de camaret à d'autres pays des
balkans qui est qui eux attendent depuis
des années
voilà on vient de finir à une belle
photo de famille à 27 plus six pays des
balkans occidentaux
six pays des balkans occidentaux pour le
moins amer a d'ailleurs le premier
ministre albanais edi rama a dit
l'ukraine ne doit pas se faire
d'illusions sous-entendu on attend
drôlement longtemps dans l'antichambre
de l'union européenne trop longtemps à
son goût en ce qui le concerne
effectivement cette candidature sa
candidature pour l'ouverture des
négociations parce qu'ils sont au stade
le plus avancé avec la macédoine du nord
macédoine du nord c'est la bulgarie qui
bloque qui bloque parce que il y à une
minorité
bulgare et puis la question de l' usage
de la langue bulgare bref des questions
nationalistes très forte et donc elle
bloque l'accession de deux pays et puis
il y avait aussi
des trois pays qui ont signé en faveur
de ce que la bosnie herzégovine
reçoivent le même statut de candidat que
l'ukraine par exemple et là ça ne marche
pas non plus donc on voit bien que ces
pays des balkans ils ont voulu rentrer
dans le club européen à la suite d'une
terrible guerre entre 91 et 95 de l'ex
yougoslavie et aujourd'hui ils sont pour
le moins bloqué puis surtout ils sont
aussi en bisbille ce qu'il a servi par
exemple est très pro russe dans son
approche elle continue à livrer du gaz
russe et contourne les sanctions donc on
voit bien aussi que c'est un terrain de
jeu de la russie très fort et que cela
crée des dissensions entre ses pays des
balkans occidentaux et ça ça fait
effectivement pas les affaires des
européens merci caroline de camaret
c'est vrai christian lequesne que
l'ukraine a obtenu ce statut en un temps
record et on le voit ça suscite de la
rancoeur chez les balkans
et oui parce que ça fait ça fait presque
dix ans aussi que
ils ont obtenu le statut de caen 2-2
quand tu vois qu'ils
ont honte hard si vous voulez ouvrir des
négociations d'adhésion avec certains
d'entre eux c'est le cas de l'albanie et
de la macédoine nord alors il est
possible qu'à l'issue du sommet entre
l'union européenne et des balkans qui va
se tenir là à bruxelles demain il y un
déblocage décision du conseil européen
parce que cette cette question de la
langue bulgare est une question
absolument absolument absurde ce sont
les bulgares qui prétendent que le
macédonien ne peut pas être reconnu
comme une langue en tant que tel et donc
qu'il ne faut pas parler de langue
macédonienne or cette dure pour les
macédoniens parce qu'avant ça c'était la
grèce qui ne voulait pas de
l'utilisation du terme macédoine parce
qu'elle estimait qu'elle avait sa propre
macédoine donc vous voyez tout ça est
très est très compliqué mais en tout cas
comme edi rama le premier ministre
albanel a dit aussi ce matin ce qui est
certain c'est que ces pays ont déjà fait
le travail d'adaptation si vous prenez
la question par exemple
de l'épuration de la justice l'albanie a
épuré une bonne partie des juges
corrompus ça ne veut pas dire que le
système fonctionne de manière tout à
fait idéal loin de là mais voilà donc on
comprend que les balkans occidentaux
veulent aussi con con qu'on l'ait que le
processus d'élargissement
soit relancé en leur faveur en quelque
sorte par là il faut bien dire les
choses il était un peu sous le tapis
voilà le système ne fonctionne pas de
manière idéale dites-vous emmanuel
macron lui vend quelque sorte réformer
ce système il avance l'idée de
communauté politique
cette idée va en quelque sorte passé son
épreuve du feu aujourd'hui à bruxelles
est ce qu'on en sait davantage sur ce
projet c'est une sorte de sas d'entrée
dans l'union européenne oui alors c'est
une idée française d'ailleurs qui n'a
qui n'a rien de nouveau si je puis dire
parce que dans les années 60 le général
de gaulle avait déjà pensé à une
communauté politique qu'on appelait les
plan fouchet après c'est le président
mitterrand 1991 qui avait parler d'une
confédération européenne monsieur macro
maintenant parle de communauté peulhe
compagnie des six boulet c'est qu'il y
ait une salle datant en quelque sorte
qui permettent aux pays candidats de
partager des objectifs politiques sans
partager les objectifs économiques
notamment du marché de la monnaie unique
etc alors je crois que le projet comme
toujours dans les projets politiques
vous savez ils sont annoncés dans un
discours et puis ensuite on essaie de
leur maître du contenu mérite d'être
d'être précisé je vois quelques
contradictions du côté de la proposition
française notamment le fait que l'on
souhaite aussi y placer par exemple la
grande bretagne je trouve que c'est un
très mauvais très mauvais message que
l'on envoie ou pays aux pays candidats
tout simplement parce que la grande
bretagne de près temps à entrer dans
l'union européenne or eux ce qu'ils
veulent c'est justement une structure
d'attentes qui leur permettent ensuite
d'entrer dans l'union donc il ne faut
pas leur donner l'impression que la
salle d'attentes devienne un purgatoire
merci beaucoup christian lequesne pour
vous éléments de compréhension
professeur à sciences po et on l'a
compris spécialiste des questions
européennes